♪ ♪
>> Sean: JOINING US NOT TO
REACT TO ALL OF TODAY'S BIG
NEWS, HOLDING PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE, DEEP STATE, PEOPLE
THAT ABUSE POWER, THE BIGGEST
CORRUPTION SCANDAL WE HAVE SEEN.
TEXAS SENATOR TED CRUZ IS WITH
US.
SENATOR, BETWEEN THE MEDIA AND
PEOPLE THAT WE ENTRUST WITH THE
POWERFUL TOOLS OF INTELLIGENCE,
TO SEE THAT THEY RIGGED AN
INVESTIGATION WITH HILLARY, THEY
LIED AND COMMITTED FRAUD BEFORE
FISA COURTS, PURPOSEFULLY, WE
NOW KNOW, BECAUSE THEY WERE ALL
WARNED ABOUT WHO PAID FOR IT,
THEY OMITTED THAT.
STEELE ALL ABOUT DEFEATING
TRUMP, AND THEN BLUDGEONING THE
PRESIDENT, TRYING TO UNDO A DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT, YOU ARE A
CONSTITUTIONAL SCHOLAR.
YOU, I THINK, APPRECIATE HOW
SEVERE THIS IS FOR THE COUNTRY.
HOW DO WE RECTIFY THIS SO IT
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN?
>> LET ME SAY FIRST OF ALL, THIS
WEEKEND WAS A VERY GOOD WEEKEND
FOR THE PRESIDENT, BUT EVEN MORE
FUNDAMENTALLY, IT WAS A VERY
GOOD WEEKEND FOR THE COUNTRY.
WE'VE HAD NOW TWO YEARS OF THIS
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATION, AND DURING THE
ENTIRE TIME, VIRTUALLY EVERY
DEMOCRAT AND ALL OF THE MEDIA
HAS BEEN BREATHLESSLY COVERING
EVERY MINUTE OF IT, INSISTING
COLLUSION, COLLUSION, COLLUSION,
COLLUSION.
WELL, WE NOW HAVE THE REPORT
FROM A SPECIAL COUNSEL AND THEY
CONCLUDED THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE,
ZERO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
THAT'S A BIG DEAL.
NOT ONLY THAT, BUT WE ALSO NOW
KNOW THAT BOTH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR AND
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD
ROSENSTEIN CONCLUDED THAT NONE
OF THE EVIDENCE SUPPORTS THE
CHARGES OF OBSTRUCTION FOR
JUSTICE -- OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, WHICH MEANS EVERYTHING
THE DEMOCRATS AND MEDIA HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR TWO YEARS
WAS LACKING IN A FACTUAL BASIS.
AND THE ENTIRE MEDIA HAS EGG ON
THEIR FACE, AND WHAT ARE THEY
DOING NOW?
THEY ARE NOT APOLOGIZING OR
BACKTRACKING, THEY ARE NOT
SAYING "GOSH, FACTS WERE WRONG,"
INSTEAD, THEY ARE ATTACKING, WE
ARE SEEING EVERY DEMOCRAT.
TO SAY "NEVER MIND ABOUT
COLLUSION, NEVER MIND ABOUT
CRIMES OR EVIDENCE," AND MARK MY
WORDS, SEAN, THE HOUSE DEMOCRATS
ARE GOING TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT ANYWAY, NOT BECAUSE OF
ANY EVIDENCE, NOT BECAUSE OF ANY
CRIMES, BUT BECAUSE OF THE FACT
HE IS DONALD TRUMP AND THEY HATE
DONALD TRUMP.
IT IS SHOWING JUST HOW EXTREME
THEY ARE.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, YOU WENT UP
AGAINST A GUY, BETO O'ROURKE, AS
THEY CALL HIM, I HAVE MY OWN
NAMES FOR HIM, I WON'T DRAG YOU
INTO MY MASS.
I GOT TO TELL YOU SOMETHING,
I'VE SEEN BENJAMIN NETANYAHU AS
A CHURCH ALIEN FIGURE THAT WAS
ALL ALONE, THE SOLE VOICE OF
MORAL CLARITY AGAINST MODERN
EVIL IN OUR TIME, UNTIL
DONALD TRUMP GOT INTO OFFICE,
AND I SEE O'ROURKE LITERALLY
WENT AFTER NETANYAHU AS AN ALLY
OF RACIST, AND WE KNOW THAT
REUTERS COVERED THE REAL STORY
OF YOUR OPPONENT FOR OVER A YEA
YEAR.
THEY MADE A DEAL WITH BETO TO
HURT YOU IN THAT ELECTION AND
HELP HIM.
>> WELL, LISTEN, WHEN IT COMES
TO MEDIA BIAS, THE REUTERS STORY
IS TRULY A SMOKING GUN.
BACK IN 2017, THEY HAD EVIDENCE
THAT BETO MAY HAVE COMMITTED
MULTIPLE FELONIES.
THE REPORTER INTERVIEWED BETO ON
THE RECORD, AND HE CONFIRMED IT,
BUT THEN THEY CUT A DEAL AND
SAID WE WANT TO REPORT ON IT
UNTIL AFTER THE 2018 ELECTION.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY WANT THE DEMOCRAT
TO WIN, THEY WANTED BETO TO BEAT
ME.
NOW THAT BETO IS RUNNING AGAINST
BERNIE AND ALL OF THE OTHER
LEFTISTS, NOW REUTERS WILL
REPORT IT.
THE MEDIA IS IN BED WITH THE FAR
LEFT WING OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU, THIS ALSO
REVEALS, I MEAN, YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT PRIME MINISTER NETANYAHU,
WHO I KNOW WELL AND CONSIDER A
FRIEND, AND CHURCH ALIEN IS
EXACTLY THE RIGHT ADJECTIVE FOR
HIM.
ONE OF THE THINGS THIS
REVIEWS -- LISTEN, BETO IS
TRYING TO APPEAL TO THE EXTREME
LEFT AND THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
ONE OF THE WAYS YOU DO THAT IS
LAUNCHING ANTI-ISRAEL ATTACKED
THAT I WAS AT THE AIPAC
CONFERENCE THIS WEEK, NOT A
SINGLE DEMOCRATIC PRESENCE OF
CANDIDATE CAME TO THE
CONFERENCE, AND WE SAW JUST A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO, THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES COULDN'T PASS A
SIMPLE BILL CONDEMNING
ANTI-SEMITISM.
I TELL YOU, SEAN, I'VE
INTRODUCED A RESOLUTION IN THE
SENATE CONDEMNING ANTI-SEMITISM.
I THINK WE NEED TO TAKE IT UP,
AND I THINK WE NEED TO PUT EVERY
SENATOR ON RECORD.
I HOPE THE DEMOCRATS ARE WILLING
TO CONDEMN ANTI-SEMITISM, THE
KIND OF COMMENTS THESE FRESHMAN
HOUSE MEMBERS ARE MAKING, THINGS
LIKE "IT'S ALL ABOUT THE
BENJAMIN'S," WHICH IS NOTHING
BUT AN ANTI-SEMITIC TROPE, AND I
ALSO HAVE LEGISLATION TO
FORMALLY RECOGNIZE AS A MATTER
OF STATUTE THE GOAL ON HEIGHTS
AS PART OF ISRAEL.
THIS WEEKEND, THE PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCED HE IS GOING TO DO
THAT.
I'VE BEEN URGING HIM IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DO THAT FOR
MONTHS, THAT IS A TREMENDOUS
VICTORY FOR ISRAEL AND AMERICA,
BUT WE NEED TO TAKE UP AND PASS
MY LEGISLATION TO PUT IN FEDERAL
LAW THAT THE GOAL ON HEIGHT IS
PART OF THE NATION OF ISRAEL.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, SENATOR,
THAT IS UNFAIR THAT YOU ARE PART
OF THE MEDIA AND YOU COVER UP,
THAT IS A CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION
IN A MAJOR WAY.
>> IS THERE ANY UNIVERSE IN
WHICH REUTERS WOULD CUT THAT